now to politics this morning republican  congressional candidate dan rodimer's  demand for another election was thrown  out by a nevada judge  rodimer's team had sued the state they  claimed there were issues in his race  with incumbent democrat susie lee  lee won the contest by thirteen thousand  votes today a clark county district  court judge ruled that roe dimer did not  have  a rather the judge ruled he did not have  jurisdiction over roe dimer's complaint  beyond that the judge said even if he  could rule on this issue  rodimer would lose this is one of  several republican-led election lawsuits  to fail in nevada courts